Brittany wrote in saying I've heard you
complain about dangerous and annoying
drivers and other people's driving
decisions do you think you are a good
driver this may shock you Brittany I do
think that I'm a good driver I do now
obviously we were just talking about
cognitive biases and heuristics I am
sure that I am a victim of cognitive
biases and all sorts of the mechanisms
that distort our understanding of
reality sure but I am I believe that I
can take a somewhat empirical approach
at this in terms of the accidents that
I've been in or rather not been in the
conversations that I have with other
people about my driving vs. their
driving and how people don't tell me
that they believe that I make bad
decisions when driving people don't tell
me that they are unsafe with me when
driving etc etc and in terms of my
observations you can also learn a lot
about what people observe about other
drivers and there are many people if you
don't notice other people's erratic
driving you may not be a particularly
aware driver because if you are a part
of being good driver is being an aware
driver and recognizing the erratic
driving of others I believe is a big
part of being a good driver oneself I
think so too i think people just want to
believe they're good drivers because it
for most of us it's a thing that we do
just about every day depending on where
you live right in it yeah you know it's
something that you know as an extension
of us our ability to do something when
we're tested to do it every single day
yeah so you know there's obviously going
to be a bias towards confirmation of
their own abilities to do it but you
have to look at the objective measures
have you caused any accidents do you get
speeding tickets with any regularity any
moving violations those are the things
that we can test and obviously that has
an effect on your insurance because
that's the measure that they used to use
this so I not only say I'm a good driver
I'm not a good driver i generally agree
with you however there are comparatively
so few police officers on the road that
i see people almost daily in boss
massachusetts known for terrible driving
in boston at the epicenter of terrible
driving i see people every day on the
road who should not have a license based
on the things that they do I mean a
total lack of awareness of what's going
on around them and even being such a bad
driver it's still not that likely that
police are going to notice you and if
they do you'll get one ticket it
probably won't change your driving
habits it's actually really hard to lose
your license because you're a terrible
driver and I would argue that the
licensing process should be more strict
I believe that it should be more
difficult to get a license should you
have to have tests recurring after you
get your license I think that's a good
idea at this point when you're 16 17 you
take the initial road test but after
that you know you just have to have your
vision checked very basic things you
don't have it tested again I think that
there should be more frequent driving
test then you get your license when
you're 16 and a half in some states or
that I know that that varies and then
you're not tested until you reach a
certain age at which you're the state
you live in is determined that you
should have your eyes tested for
provision for driving I why wouldn't you
have regular relicensing test it makes
sense to me it's one of those things
that even though it's not a right people
consider it to be a right of theirs and
it's very hard especially to go after
the elderly for a per se to say even
though you've been driving for 60 years
we're going to the government's going to
take your license away it's just most
people wouldn't have the heart to do
that so I don't think it's something
that would pull very well it probably
wouldn't but this is a real and present
danger and there are countless accidents
as a result of people wildly just doing
crazy things the things i see and by the
way with the cell phones almost always
on the highway from half a mile away and
see someone in the fast lane going 62 I
see someone changing lanes in a way that
just doesn't look quite right 99 out of
100 times you drive by and they're on a
cell phone and that is just such a
danger right now it's one of those
things that really get me upset because
I don't get angry too often and I don't
really think I used the anger that I
have built up in any sort of road rage
but I'm lay on the horn I'll do that
yeah oh it's atrocious what's going on
out there in Massachusetts be careful
the best experience I had for calming
down my feeling that message
drivers are terrible was driving in
Italy when I was on making not on my
vacation driving in Naples Italy you
will come back to the US and just think
that the driving is fantastic which I
needed because it's so bad in Boston
that I needed to have something worse
for comparison to then feel more calm he
driving here I like to think that even
though the driving is notorious
notoriously bad here people actually
have some sort of skill with what
they're doing so maybe if they cut you
off of course you're going to get angry
about it but they're able to get out of
the way in a certain amount of point
where it's like well you know what I
kind of respect that move though they're
not necessarily being unsafe yeah I've
not seen that I you're more optimistic
than I am on that one but yes to answer
your question Brittany I'm actually a
very good driver